prime minister and you've said that we
need to take the pain on energy bills to
defeat Putin but there's a question
about who takes the pain isn't there and
you've decided that it will ultimately
be the taxpayer rather than energy
companies with those excess profits of
170 billion pounds who are going to take
the pain how is that fair
well first of all the priority for me
was making sure that families who were
worried about this winter had a
guarantee that their bills would not go
up Beyond 2 500 pounds that was very
important
people were worried about struggling
through the winter businesses were
worried about going under so I was
determined that we took bold action to
deal with that that will cost money that
will cost money it costs a taxpayer
money won't it will cost it will cost
the government money but what we are
doing is taxpayers what we are doing is
writing the difficulties we had in the
past by making sure that we're investing
in our long-term energy Supply because
we should have invested in it 20 years
ago
and this is why nuclear is important
it's why it's important we're using
resources in the North Sea is why it's
important we're entering some long-term
Supply agreements that we should have
done before well I would until that
strategy What I Wouldn't allow is for
the burden to fall on people and
businesses at this very difficult time
but prime minister just to be clear and
it and it you know ideologically could
be a valid point and ultimately you
would rather the taxpayer will have to
foot this bill ultimately not business
that I think it isn't it I think it's
worth saying though and the child
actually just acknowledge that
ultimately we do pay in the end
well I what the chances will be
outlining on Friday is exactly how this
will be paid for but I think it's
important to say that the impact of the
announcement we've already made will be
reducing inflation so it's likely to
reduce inflation by Five Points it's
likely to increase economic growth and
we're also entering long-term Supply
agreements to mitigate the cost so the
cost to the taxpayer is not what has
been projected I think that's very
important to understand but so I lost
150 billion it's not a hundred children
will be laying it out in more
details 100 billion under 100 billion
the cost is mitigated first of all by
the overall benefits of the economy but
also the fact that we are now investing
in the long term Supply just on this
quickly Labor's policy to tax the energy
companies are supported by 68 of the
public according to polls you're
prepared to be unpopular aren't you yes
yes I am
what is important to be is that we grow
the British economy because that is what
will ultimately deliver higher wages
more investment in towns and cities
across the country that is what will
ultimately deliver more money into
people's pockets and it will also enable
us to fund the Public Services like the
National Health Service and in order to
get that economic growth Britain has to
be competitive and if we put up taxes if
we have arbitrary taxes on energy
companies if we have high corporation
tax we're not going to get that
investment and growth which will
ultimately damage
damage opportunities in this country and
that's what I'm bothered about what I
care about is are there those jobs there
in the future those high paid jobs
Industries like technology Industries
like energy that's what is motivating me
prime minister just let's go on to
another policy then tax cuts you're
planning to reverse the corporation tax
cut rise you're scrapping National
Insurance increases a big boost to Big
Business and a tax cut that
disproportionately benefits rich people
in this country is that fair I don't
accept this argument that
cutting taxes is somehow unfair I mean
what what we know is people on higher
incomes generally pay more tax so when
you reduce taxes there is often a
disproportionate benefit because those
people pay more taxes in the first place
we should be setting our tax policy on
the basis of what is going to help our
country become successful what is going
to deliver that economy that benefits
everybody in our country and what what I
don't accept is the idea that tax cuts
on business don't help people in general
of course they help people in general
because we want businesses to be more
productive we want more investment and
that ultimately means so jobs and growth
and opportunities right across this is
quite a shift in policy in terms of
what's gone before what you're saying is
you're happy for the rich to get richer
if it grows the economy and if that
makes you very politically unpopular
with the wider public you you will do
that as prime minister what would I
believe about what what the people I
speak to and I've done a lot of
traveling around the country over the
past few months what people care about
is in the town or city I live in are the
jobs and opportunities are the new
businesses investing does my High Street
look better than it used to look you
know our roads being built can I get a
mobile phone signal that's what people
care about and that is what I am
absolutely focused on delivering and I'm
prepared fairness as well I am prepared
and they do care about fairness prime
minister as well and they might not
think it's fair that their children have
to fund government debt to fund say tax
cuts for big business or energy bills
and then they ultimately pick up the
bill their children do all their
children's children they'll think it's
not fair you understand that you can
disagree with that but you understand
that's it that's a particular point of
view you're expressing which is what
people on the left after politics often
express what I'm saying is that by
keeping taxes low and growing the
economy we will get more tax revenues in
and actually that will succeed that will
succeed in the long term in bringing the
opportunities that people want to see so
that's that's right some of the public
think there should be a windfall tax so
it's not necessarily the left it's a
large proportion of Voters but like a
policy that you're not back in just to
point that out to you
um just in terms of no windfall types of
us incorporation tax Bankers bonus cap
being dropped you said the city was the
Crown Jewel of the British economy you
want to
drop caps on Bankers bonuses to attract
investment to the city again a deeply
unpopular policy but one you're prepared
to take because you believe it will grow
the economy what I know is that there
are tens of billions of investment that
are ready to go into businesses right
across the country into manufacturing
businesses into the north of England in
life sciences industry and what we need
to do is get that investment from the
city of London right across our country
and yes I am prepared to take the
measures and change the rules and the
chancellor is prepared to do that in
order to get that investment because the
priority is getting investment into
manufacturing industry one of the
reasons that we have relatively low
growth in this country is we haven't had
enough capital investment and yet we
have you know one of the world's best
financial services centers so what I
want to see is that money in the city of
London put to good use across our
country and yes I'm prepared to do what
it takes to get that money
just one other thing prime minister did
you recognize that this set of policies
could be an electoral a side note for
you with the public that they will see a
prime minister who is on the side of big
business and bankers and not on the side
of working people
what I think working people will judge
me and my government on at the next
election is
have I got a good job are my wages going
up
have I seen improvements in my town or
my city
it has the road being built can I get a
mobile signal do I am I getting a GPS am
I getting a GP appointment as quickly as
I can that's what people care about and
that's what I believe people will vote
on just final quick question interest
rate rise later this week potentially a
decision being taken by the bank of
England I know it's nothing to do with
you they set the rate what's your
message to people out there that will be
watching this how desperately worried
about Rising mortgage bills and interest
rate Rises it's going to be a rough
winter isn't it we are in very difficult
Economic Times we're facing Putin's war
in Ukraine which has pushed up the
prices of energy we have also got the
aftermath of covid I'm determined that
my government takes every step and
strains everything you to help people to
get the economy going to make sure that
we have a successful
economy and country that can weather
this very very difficult storm that
we're facing rough winter we get through
it we will get through it I promise to
thank you so much thank you